en fait c'est considéré comme une forme
un peu légère du théâtre se voir ce chez
les gens ça alors que ça devrait
également être autre chose
le café de la gare par exemple c'est une
formule lit ou c'est une formule
nouvelle fugue et
[Musique]
toujours prêt à tester autre couleur va
tomber sur un chiffre de 1 et 20 et ce
chiffre hausse comme à la baisse de prix
non je voudrais savoir comment ça vous
comment vous vous débrouillez c'est
canal farah se [ __ ] dans crainte
qu'ont truc on se dit bon il ya quand
même c'est une coopérative
non c'est salir la c6 et la déclenche en
bordel n'y a rien d'écrit qu'on doivent
respecter si un soir il vient pas j'ai
bien on n'a qu'à fermer donne bien tout
on pourra lui dire séparément nous admet
être avoir plus avancé il dira non à
part dont je suis pas venu non c'est pas
c'est beau ça mais dans les faits de
s'installer une bombe a comme ça au
niveau copains mais l'a aimé cet accord
ça je suis bien terme mardi d'un des
lois il ya des pourcentages de gains de
bénéfices des pachas tout c'est que ça
soit écrit la 6e tels que ça change il
est dans le bourg ou comment tu
travailles comment vous travaillez
maintenant je travaille on travaille pas
je m'engage tout il ya des gens dans la
salle y avait toujours un pied
contre toujours un truc c'est très très
très très mauvais parce qu'on n'a pas
répété puis ça finit par devenir un peu
meilleur je suis vachement la nausée
dans l'avion forme
à force de jouer devant les gens ont
fini par trouver des dates à vienne
comme gérant un pote critiques qui sont
venus qu'ils ont massacré au départ en
étant on a le temps de se remettre sur
le cas jusqu'ici les écuyers sketch
c'est génial c'est tout ce mois mais les
éléments c'est justement il y en a un
qui clignote qu'écrit puis comme le haut
puis reprend d'abord ce qu'ont dit les
autres puisqu'elle d'ores et déjà fait
avec ça et puis hénin qui est pas
content alors il va faire est-ce que je
suis leur passé puis les autres ne
veulent pas savoir où ça marche à notre
grand regret ce que les gens découvrent
pas plus il ya des tas de gens voient le
film on voit les films autour de nous
tout ça quand je pense que ronde parmi
nous il ya des prix d'interprétation ça
fait dix ans déjà qu'on l'isae personnes
encore donner des cours aux mains c'est
panique à travailler plus c'est pas vous
qui écrivez plus que les autres non mais
ces satanés boxe il cloue beaucoup à
chaque fois qu'un truc qui t'aiment dans
la boîte peut donner l'assaut mais c'est
un coureur de fond
voyez en lot ont travaillé sans ossature
mais essayer mais j'aime faire une
démonstration et six mois de préparation
quand on est obligé les choses se font
voilà alors davantage des chefs et tous
et que l'on peut décliner sa
responsabilité ce qu'on a une 1 une
fonction s'il ya plus de chef
on a toutes les fonctions alors
affolement mais affolement de 80
personnes valides la force que ça
représente
c'est plus fort que l'organisation mais
il ya des moments où on trouve les
choses sérieuses font ça se passe pour
le partage de l'argent c'est pas sérieux
du tout c'est pas sérieux mais voilà à
tous la télévision je bouge pas facile
avant droit d'y replonger ce soit m
injecter viennent me voir
[Musique]